vorgestern um diese zeit in berlin meine
damen und herren klimaaktivisten legen
wieder einmal den verkehr lahm
autofahrer stehen im stau wir berichten
die ganze zeit live und unser reporter
geht durch die reihen und dann lässt
brian der brummifahrer mal so richtig
alles raus ja und er wird über nacht mit
einem satz berühmt der schon anderthalb
millionen mal hier bei bild angeklickt
wurde und wir wollen natürlich noch mal
rein
[Musik]
sie sollen bei den politikern hochgehen
und nicht hier uns und wir haben alle zu
tun sie machen ihren job ich mache
meinen job und was machen die
stirn dabei es reicht wir können
zufrieden sein dass ich jetzt ein
schöner effekt habe dass ich entspannt
bin ich schon nach vorne ja
da ist ja der entspannte kult
brummifahrer brian ihr bei uns im studio
schön entspannt im und morgen ja
auch da draußen hallo die entspannt bis
heute morgen super der erste kaffee
getrunken und habe eine
erholsame nacht gehabt das ist
über nacht plötzlich so berühmt zu
werden eineinhalb millionen mal
angeklickt dieser legendäre satz ja ich
fühlt sich das an ja also es scheint
noch kein groupie vor der tür zum glück
möchte ich auch nicht an sondern auch
verheiratet ja nie verheiratet bin ich
noch nicht aber feste freunde genau
feste freundin und ja wir ja auch
bekannt geworden ist was hat sie denn
gedacht ja sie jeder der mich kennt der
weiß wie ich bin offen und direkt und
das ist mir wichtig also die steht voll
hinter leader klar die war jetzt auch
nicht irgend so ein bisschen peinlich
berührt vielleicht von der geschichte
wenn ja an freundinnen im netz dann
immer drauf klicken und sehen wo planer
hat aber nach der breiten einen
rausgehauen ja viele haben gefragt ist
hat es hat es wirklich hat er das
wirklich gesagt ja ja ja aber gut so
sind auf den straßen da kommt er doch
mal was was man vielleicht nicht sagen
sollte oder nicht so ins fernsehen
bringen sind aber du brauchst jetzt
nicht dass uns gesagt wenn dann hätte
ich es nicht gesagt wie war denn so das
feedback hast du positive reaktionen
bekommen also eigentlich habe ich nur
positives feedback bekommen
und ja es gibt auch welche die es nicht
mögen aber was sagen die leute so cool
endlich einmal etwas sagt und der
deutschen
auf die kacke ist eine ganz interessante
hat ja selber auch gefilmt als somit den
aktivisten gesprochen hat das ist auch
schon millionenfach
angeklickt worden dass das haben uns
auch mal kurz an
[Musik]
was machen sie hier man hat dann
passiert
sowas machen sie
ja hab ich schon angerufen also jetzt
mach das weg kommt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also so ist wenn man
es auch wenn du nicht entspannt möchte
ich nicht drüber reden
nicht viel anders also gewalt ist keine
lösung und im straßenverkehr sowieso
nicht das ist ganz klar aber
ehrlicherweise die klimaaktivisten die
können danach freundinnen schon
irgendwie dankbar sein glaube ich oder
weil wenn man sich jetzt mal überlegt
wie du so drauf gewesen wärst wenn sie
nicht für die entspannung gesorgt hätte
ja gefährlich werden können vielleicht
ja situationsbedingt weil die waren ja
auch in dem sinne friedlich und haben
sich da bloß hingesetzt und festgeklebt
war aber auch ein großes problem ist
ich habe immer im rückspiel geguckt und
hab gedacht ich bin jetzt feuerwehr
krankenwagen et cetera vorbei will nicht
klar da müssen wir tatsächlich jetzt ein
bisschen ernster werden die
klimaaktivisten haben ja tatsächlich wie
lange hat das ganze gedauert weil haben
sie dann da gestand meine stunden ja
wenn man sich dann überlegt dass da
waren feuerwehrwagen oder irgend was ich
will ist das natürlich schon ein
bisschen schwierig was genau hatte ich
in dem moment so aufgeregt die tatsache
dass sie da waren einfach dass sie nicht
reden wollten dass sie vielleicht auch
einfach nicht geredet hatte ja auf einer
ihm aber nur kurz und den heiß begehrten
weil man sieht es das reden bringt bei
denen ich viel weil sie setzen sich
trotzdem und ja hast du denn
grundsätzlich für das anliegen klima und
so weiter verständnis eigentlich
selbstverständlich aber nicht so wir
haben alle einen beitrag dazu leisten
dann fängt eine trennung an oder dass
man mit der bvg fährt et cetera pp seine
sachen länger trägt als nur einmal und
das gehört alles was dazu aber jeder
einzelne muss sich daran beteiligen und
nicht so eine show zu machen sein
gefährtin meinung du hast hier uns auch
noch mal was wenn es mitgebracht hat ja
was sollten sie bereits kleine
erinnerung dienen mein guter freund
marinelli hat mir
das als andenken
das ist auch nicht schön das wird das
bett gehängt oder nein nein
wo man es jeden tag sieht wo ich daran
erinnert werde und gleichzeitig habe
aber noch nicht gemacht und also mehr
jobs sagen dass
ich mit will man natürlich sagen du bist
gut jetzt ja da brauchst dann
tatsächlich ein wunderschönes t shirt
von merchandise vielleicht kommen noch
ein paar tassen in die produktion
noch verkaufen vielleicht wirst
darum geht es jetzt nicht also ich will
ja gar kein geschäft draus machen man
einfach nur
das zum ausdruck bringen ich muss sagen
es ist einfach herzerfrischend ja zum
einen ist natürlich typisch berlin muss
man sagen würde vielleicht woanders
nicht nur hier aber es ist will du hast
einfach aus der seele gesprochen mit
einem woche test von dem fernseher
normalerweise so nicht sagt und deshalb
wahrscheinlich auch eben der große
zuspruch weil man gesehen hat es ist der
wirklich ehrlich herausgekommen make
love not war so könnte man das
eigentlich ganz nett unterstreichen und
wir wollen natürlich auch noch mal ein
großes dankeschön sagen nicht nur an
dich für diesen wirklich tollen
fernsehen moment den wir uns beschert
hat sondern wir wollen auch dankeschön
sagen an deine liebe freundin weil wir
jetzt auch festgestellt haben sie ist
der grund warum das ganze nicht weiter
eskaliert ist und warum da keine blutige
nasen im endeffekt in den wagen saßen
oder auf die straßen insofern haben wir
damals kleines vorbereitung ich hoffe
wenn sie jetzt zu schaut das ist für sie
ja ich hoffe sie freut sich darüber
gerne mitnehmen vielen dank ja und
vielen dank
also brian der brummige brummifahrer der
aber durchaus entspannt